And I think if I'm being completely
honest, one of the intimidations to me
of Islam is not the content of Islam.
When I when I'm thinking about, oh, I'm
going to talk to a Muslim, the thing
that kind of intimidates me is
at least the videos you see online.
>> Yes.
Um they they appear strong. They appear
firm. They appear like, oh, oh, like I
know better than you do. And it's almost
like the way that the information is
delivered, it's like they delivered it
in a way where ah you're not going to be
able to respond to this. So, how how are
you
what kind of I don't know. I guess for
me practically, not even just for me,
but for other people that are listening,
kind of like, how do we when we're
talking to Muslims not get intimidated
by their rhetoric?
Second Timothy 1:7 says, "The Lord did
not give you a spirit of timidity,
but a boldness, right?"
>> Yeah. And sound mind. And Romans 8:15,
you haven't been handed over spirit
spirit of fear. Fear is a weapon of
Satan.
What happens
when you get bullied
and you don't stand up to the bully?
He keeps bullying you, right?
>> Yeah. What happens when you stand up to
the bully? Then you expose yellow belly.
There's got a yellow streak, right?
>> Yeah. Muslims
because their religion starts from
Satan. Satan is a narcissist. Muhammad
is a narcissist.
Satan loves control. Muhammad loved
control. So, what do narcissistic
bullies do? They try to intimidate you,
bully you to control you. Mhm. When you
stand up to them, then you expose their
cowardice.
>> Mhm.
Then their victim mentality comes uh
comes to the fore- forefront. The
problem with Christians in the West
I don't know why or how this started.
Christians in the West equate being
Christian with being soft and
effeminate.
Mhm. Yeah, that's
>> This is what I call the
feminization of Christian men. I'm not
trying to get into the red pill. I don't
know. I'm not no Andrew Tate. That's
extreme. That's satanic. Nonetheless,
there are some truths and all lies.
If you read the Bible carefully, look at
early church history, the prophets and
the apostles were not sissies. Right.
>> They were bold lions and they would put
people in their place.
They'd even insult people and even curse
people who deserved it. It's all
throughout scripture. But,
for some reason something happened in
Christian history
where we did a 180, where now if you're
bold or rude or in someone's face,
you're now considered un-Christ-like.
Have you read how Jesus talked to the
Pharisees and the scribes and the money
changers? You brood of vipers.
>> them fools. And if you look at the word
idiot, stupid, he called them
adulterers. And through the prophets he
said very graphic things about them.
Right? So, but I'm not Again,
nonetheless,
so I
my style, I'm very rude. I'm in your
face cuz you know, sadly,
I am extreme at times cuz I'm a sinner.
But I balance out the other side that's
too weak and soft and timid. We need the
balance of
boldness,
biblical masculinity for men,
and not be intimidated by bullying
tactics cuz you have the truth, they
don't. So, what they
lack in substance, they make up with
barking.
And you got to see through that.
Yeah, question question then on top of
that. Well, I'm I'm thinking of 1 Peter
3:15, right? It says, "You know, in your
hearts honor Christ your your Lord as
holy and always be prepared to make a
defense to anyone who asks for the hope
inside of you."
>> the
the context. Whoever's asking you,
give an apologetic,
do so with gentleness and reverence.
To whom? To those who ask you.
What if they're not asking cuz they want
to know? What if they're asking to bully
you, intimidate you, to blaspheme?
The same Peter then in 2 Peter 2 says to
those people who are perverts and
perverting gospel, he calls them wild
beasts, good-for-nothing but
destruction." And he calls them dogs and
pigs who return to their
vomit. That's same Peter in 2 Peter 2.
Mhm.
So, there is a balance. I know it's 1
Peter 3, but what's the context? Yeah.
Whoever asks you Well, what if they're
not asking you to learn? What if they're
trying to bully you, intimidate you?
What if they're trying to censor you?
What if they're trying to mock you? Then
read how they treated such people, like
in Acts 13:6 to 12, where there was a
false prophet Elymas Bar-Jesus, who
opposed Paul's preaching in order to
hinder him, cuz he was a sorcerer.
Paul calls him "You son of the devil,
enemy of all righteousness." And cursed
him with blindness.
Called him, "You son of the devil. You
enemy of all that is righteous." Mhm.
Does that sound like he was being
gentle?
No. No, that does not sound like that. I
I guess one of the things that I
First of all, let me let me say this.
I'm right there with you on this side of
Too much.
>> feminine and and so it's too much. You
do have a balance. I'm right there with
you. I think the thing that like is hard
for me sometimes, particularly with like
Islam, is is that issue you run into. A
lot of them they don't want to learn.
They want to get a gotcha on you. Well,
that's what I'm I'm Is it Is it throwing
pearls onto swine? Is it So, then then
here's my follow-up question to that. Is
there and this is all me just genuinely
asking trying to understand.
Is there a time and place to then throw
pearls onto swine?
No, you never have a time and place to.
What you do is what Paul did. When he
saw Elymas wasn't interested, what did
he do?
He cursed them and ridiculed them.
That's their treatment. You son of the
devil.
Enemy of all that is righteousness. You
will not stop perverting the ways of the
Lord.
He didn't even entertain him to talk. He
cursed him. When I say cursed, not like
cursed like effort F No, no, that's not
what I'm talking about. He rebuked him
and
invoked God's judgment on him. That's
what I mean by cursed.
>> And yeah, yeah, yeah. hey your your
mother you know I'm not saying that.
>> [laughter]
>> Right, right. So, when you see those
people
you are to rebuke them, chasing them,
block them, and remove them. To engage
them
is to do what Jesus says don't do
because they're not there to listen.
They're there
to clickbait, they're there for clips,
they're there for numbers and money.
And so you are now being used by their
father the devil to allow them to
blaspheme the Lord, mock the Lord,
attack the Bible, ridicule Christians,
and cause weak Christians lose their
faith. So, you're complicit. Very
interesting. Wow.
>> So, then what is the
I guess
like
Yeah, that's very fascinating. So, then
is there does the Bible then say there
is a purpose for exposing then? Does the
Bible talk about
>> Ephesians 5:11 expose the deeds of
darkness. But exposing what they do and
their tactics is one thing. Engaging
them in just
you know, a shouting match or engaging
them when you know they're not listening
and they're going to talk over you
then what's the purpose in that? There
is no purpose. In fact, you know what
Titus 3:10-11 says? What does it say?
After the first or second warning
avoid a heretic
a contentious person. After how many
warnings? Two. So, why do we keep doing
it? That's Titus 3:10-11. Do you have
your Bible? Look at it. I don't know if
you have it. I've got it outside in my
backpack. I got it
>> if you want to put on the screen bar
brother, biblegateway.com
homie. Great website.
>> Yep, it is. I use it. biblegateway.com
Titus 3:10-11
Titus 3:10-11 Warn a divisive person
once and then warn them a second time.
After that having have nothing to do
with them. You may be sure that such
people are warped and sinful. They are
self-condemned.
>> you keep engaging them?
Totally understand. I guess I guess
another follow-up question then is the
language the language that you've
described in the Bible Paul using to
these people even even church
>> you
a very clean
example. If I show you how graphic it
gets. Well, even well, I even know like
even the early church fathers like they
would address heretics like Very
graphic. very graphically and very
intensely. I'm right there with you.
Something that I'm trying to understand
I guess is you have the Bible who would
describe as human beings as a whole
being of a different moral value because
they're made in the image of God. The
same Jesus who said they're made in the
image of God who called them dogs and
pigs. Well, that's what I was going to
ask you is that's my question is
so then is you
is calling someone a dog or a pig or
>> you answer the question. Jesus who
created them in his image
he says they're dogs and pigs.
So, answer that. Yeah, I don't know.
That's fascinating to me.
>> Matthew 7:6 bring it up for my friend
here.
So, you can't take scripture because a
person can
corrupt themselves to such an extent
they now a face
that image of God within them and
they're worse than beast and animals.
What did Jesus say not to do? Do not
give dogs what is sacred. Do not throw
your pearls
>> the dogs that he's talking about?
The Pharisees, right? But what are they?
What are their nature?
They're people.
Humans? You mean?
>> yeah, humans.
>> You just said they're created in the
image of God.
So, Jesus created called his image
bearers dogs and pigs?
I get I guess so. I guess so.
>> guessing it's right there, brother. I'm
just so I'm so that's what's confusing
to me is because I'm like
>> to you, man? The Lord's telling you.
>> Well, I'm I no, I
>> Some image bearers of mine they're worse
than animals. They've corrupted
themselves to such an extent they are
now dogs and sons of Satan. Got you.
Okay, so it's it's not it's that they
have corrupted themselves to such a
state. I see. Okay.
>> In fact here, if you open up the screen,
my brother from a different mother,
which your screen keeps going going off.
Rebuke that demon by the power of Jesus
Christ.
Okay.
It's This is language out throughout
scripture. It's not only Jesus saying
they're dogs and pigs.
So, when it comes up, you'll see.
Uh-huh.
Peter, what did I just say? What did he
say about those who heard the gospel of
truth,
walked in the gospel of truth, but then
fell away and perverted for heresy?
You're going to see what he calls them.
So, now here it says, "Do not give Do
not give dogs what is sacred." And
that's NIV. It's a little more of a
paraphrase.
>> Yeah. "Do not throw your pearls to pigs.
If you do, they may trample them under
their feet and turn and tear you to
pieces." Mhm. Now, open up 2 Peter
chapter 2.
2 Peter chapter just right here. You're
going to see
those who came to faith, who were saved,
who were bought by the Lord, who
acknowledged the Lord,
but then they fell away to introduce
damnable heresies or licentiousness,
meaning using the grace of God as an
excuse to live immorally. Well, look how
Peter describes them, but the screen
keeps shutting off. Then we're not going
to look at 2 Peter 2.
>> Doesn't it say Doesn't it say their
faith is counted as unrighteousness? Is
that Is that Is that what it
>> Peter 2 is saying it's not about those
who came to the knowledge of truth.
You may need your Bible cuz their screen
does keep shutting down. I don't know
what you want to do.
>> really quick.
Yeah, brothers.
All right. Yeah, just get your Bible,
brother, cuz it's not going to work.
Yeah.
Jihad, brother, make sure you leave this
interview raw and unedited. Oh, we don't
edit anything.
>> Good, man. Jihad, they sent this guy, fi
sabilillah.
His name is Abdur Rahman.
Abdul al-Aswad.
Okay. Okay, you said 2 Peter 2.
>> So, I would Starting in verse one?
Verse one, what did they do? But false
prophets also rose among the people,
just as there will be false teachers
among you who will be secretly bringing
in destructive heresies.
>> right? Yep. And what are they going to
introduce? Heresies. Heresies. Okay, so
when you denying even the very Lord that
bought them?
Mhm. Right? Okay, now what what does he
say
they're good for verse 12?
It says in verse 12, but these like
irrational animals, creatures of
instinct
>> animals?
Yeah.
>> They're worse than
animals
>> Even tame dogs, they're like rabid dogs?
Yeah. It says
blaspheming about matters of which they
are ignorant will also be destroyed in
their destruction suffering wrong as the
rage for the wrong doers. So you see 2
Peter 2:12 one more time read that again
slowly, see? But these like irrational
animals, creatures of instinct born to
be caught and destroyed
>> Oh, so he says they should be destroyed?
Peter says that about image bearers of
God?
Yeah, that's very fascinating.
>> Now read 20 to 22. I love that you said
to read 20 to 22. For if after they have
escaped the defilements of the world
through the knowledge of our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ, they are again
entangled in them and overcome, the last
state has become worse for them than the
first. For it would have been better for
them never to have known
the way of the righteousness than after
knowing it to turn back from the holy
commandment delivered to them. What the
true proverb says has happened to them,
the dog returns to its own vomit.
>> nothing but rabid
dogs who eat their own vomit. And then
what else are they?
It says, and the sow after washing
herself returns to wallow.
>> They're dirty pigs.
Peter. Interesting. So I guess I guess
my my my final question on that subject
is how do you
determine
what language to use?
>> Yeah, well I don't do it perfectly. So
I'm not infallible, I'm not inspired. So
there are times I I acknowledge I cross
the line.
>> [clears throat]
>> Do I want to? No.
But myself because I'm a sinner,
imperfect, I have my own ticks.
Meaning there's certain things that
trigger me
because I'm weak.
I know when someone deserves to be
rebuked because they don't come to ask
to learn. They're coming to attack and
mock.
>> Mhm.
That's I you know, by the nature of the
question because either they will not
answer the question or when you go to
answer the question, they're already
cutting you off. That means right there
they're there to
try to prove you're wrong.
And I understand because I do that to
Muslims. I don't ask to learn. I ask to
show them why Islam is false.
But because I already know the argument
and I'm trying to answer when they cut
me off, then they show that they're not
there to listen. So I'll either block
them, get rid of them, but if they get
nasty, then Proverbs 20's here.
If you don't know how to interpret
scripture out of scripture, you're going
to create contradictions when there are
none. Mhm. Because in Proverbs 26:4-5,
those two verses contradict each other.
Right. They contradict each other.
Proverbs 26:4-5 why? Because if you go
to Proverbs 26, verses 4 and 5. First 4
says, "Don't answer a fool according to
his folly unless you become like him."
It's Proverbs 26:4.
>> Yep. Do not answer a fool according to
his folly,
according to his stupidity, foolishness.
Cuz then you'll be like him, right?
That's verse 4. Look at it. Says that,
right?
>> Answer not a fool according to his folly
unless you be like him in your unless
you be like him yourself.
>> But verse 5 contradicts that. Says,
"Answer a fool according to his folly
lest he be wise in his own eyes." So
that's a contradiction. No, it isn't.
Cuz the Bible tells you it's not black
and white. There are times in which you
ignore an idiot.
Times in which you expose an idiot to
show how stupid he is.
Why? So people can see he's stupid
because he may influence people who
think he's smart, but he's stupid and
he's dangerous. So then you got to
expose them for the sake of the flock.
Mhm. So that comes with discernment.
Yeah. But none of us have perfect
discernment and that's why I've offended
people, but if you actually look at it,
what's ironic, the language I use is all
in scripture.
People haven't watched my live stream,
so they don't know what I'm talking
about. When I say
that's Revelation 17.
The of Babylon, and all her
daughters are It's the word
Or, for example, dog, or pig,
or stupid. That's Matthew 23:17. Jesus
called them stupid. If you look at the
word fool, it means stupid. Mhm.
So, it's ironic. I use biblical
language, they don't know it because of
this
effeminization of Christian men. Mhm.
That's what And I say, "Well, hold on. I
was just reading the Bible. I just read
Matthew 23:17." "Yeah, but you're not
Jesus." But you're telling me to imitate
Jesus, right? "Oh, [snorts] only imitate
Jesus in the places you like." Mhm. I
see.
So, for example, bastard, Hebrews 12:8.
It says, "If God doesn't discipline
you," and the word is, "then you're a
bastard."
Hebrews 12:8. Wow. It's there in the
Bible, man. And if you look at the
Hebrew and Greek idioms, it's much more
graphic than in English. English, they
soften it down. Don't believe me, just
look at any comment. And I'm not here
talking about justified. I'm just saying
to answer your question. For example,
would you be shocked
if a man of God said, "I'm going to take
the of a dog and smear it on your
face"?
I think at initial hand, yeah.
>> You would, right?
>> Shocked, yeah. You have an issue with
God telling Malachi, Malachi 2:3, he
says, "Go tell the priests I'm going to
take the of their animals and smear
on their faces." It's literally the
Hebrew. Malachi 2:3. That's very
interesting.
>> So, you have a problem with Malachi. So,
why don't you get out of your Bible?
>> [laughter]
>> Wow, that's interesting.
>> Malachi 2:3, because the priests were
offering Malachi's right before Matthew.
Yeah.
The priests were offering defective
sacrifices of defective animals, and
they knew better. You know what he said?
"I'm going to take the shit" Go read the
Hebrew word.
It's what's in their intestine. The the
dung, Oh, yeah.
>> the crap, and I'm going to smear the
crap on your faces.
>> Behold, I will rebuke your offspring and
spread dung on your face.
>> What is dung, brother?
>> The dung off your offsprings and What is
that? What is that? Oh, it's poop. So,
you just told me you had a problem with
your Bible.
That's so fascinating.